to our stop her top story tonight rather
dr jesus jarrow will soon be back in his
seat as superintendent of the clark
county school district this comes more
than a month after he was originally
fired by the board of trustees then
reinstated weeks later now local
teachers say they hope things can be
done differently this time victoria saha
joins us in studio this evening with
more victoria
hey sasha it's been a lot of back and
forth between the board and dr jara and
teachers have been left in the dark when
it comes to decisions about their leader
the ones i spoke with say they don't
want a repeat of disagreements
there's a lot of frustration there for a
lot of staff after weeks of silence
staff and students at the clark county
school district are finally getting some
answers on the status of their leader
superintendent dr jesus jarrow was
ousted from his job then that decision
was rescinded by the board dr jarrah
finally releasing a statement saying in
part there are too many children in this
community that have been left behind i
won't walk away from them i don't
understand that comment and it's hurtful
to me because we're doing our very best
but at our best when we're so short of
staff dolly rowan a teacher within the
district says this time around she wants
to see some teamwork with dr jara and
the board i just feel you can't put kids
first when you don't put your staff
they need to put them last you just have
to listen to them and support them
staffing issues seems to be a common
concern amongst teachers we are really
low
you know we don't have a lot of
people to fill in positions this teacher
doesn't want to be identified because
she's scared of losing her job we're
passionate people we love what we do but
we also need to be taken care of hoping
this time around their voices can be
heard
dr jarrah will be continuing his
position on monday the next regular
school board meeting is this thursday
december 9th